What does the fictional drug Drops do, exactly?
Is it new to the Batman mythos?
And how will it play into The Penguin's criminal
ambitions?
Keep watching for what we know and where we
think things might go.
Warning: Spoilers for "The Batman" ahead.
The Gotham City that director Matt Reeves
brings to life in "The Batman" is a place
where corrupt politicians and law enforcement
work hand-in-dirty-hand with the real rulers
of the town, who live outside the law and
pay enough to keep it that way.
From gang wars to money laundering, it's a
challenging place to keep in check.
Things only get stranger when the mayor gets
killed by a creepy criminal mastermind who
loves riddles and the only reliable figure
in town is struggling to be taken seriously
because he dresses like a bat.
"I'm vengeance."
The Gotham of "The Batman" also has a serious
drug problem.
This new drug on the streets, referred to
as "Drops," is impacting every rung of the
social ladder.
But just what are these so-called Drops?
Though there are some fictional drugs that
pop up in comics and other media, Drops don't
appear in the more than eight decades of Batman's
history.
This is a new fictional drug devised by Reeves
and co-writer Peter Craig, presented within
the first few minutes of the new film.
Applied by the user like a simple eye drop,
the drug causes hyperactivity and paranoia,
as shown by District Attorney Gil Colson when
he's speaking to Selina at 44 Below.
The substance's impact on the city continues
throughout the film.
It's a festering issue bubbling underneath
Batman's greater challenge of battling the
Riddler and uncovering the corruption that
permeates the city.
From Penguin's thwarted distribution scheme,
to Batman and Gordon encountering so-called
"Drop heads" holing up in the abandoned orphanage,
Batman's war on Drops in Gotham continues
to rage on, even after he's called a hero.
For now, there aren't any answers about this
drug's future.
However, a future spin-off series on HBO Max
about The Penguin may just provide new answers.
When last we see him, Colin Farrell's Oswald
Cobblepot, aka The Penguin, is looking at
a flooded Gotham City, and seeing a new dawn,
with a wide-open space for a new crime boss
to take over Carmine Falcone's former empire.
It stands to reason, then, that the Penguin
spin-off will focus on precisely that, as
Cobblepot fights his way to the top of the
criminal empire, eventually reaching his inevitable
archvillain status.
A crime boss has got to make money somehow,
and chances are that Drops will continue to
be a crucial part of his operation.
Still, a business like this is tough, with
the competition even more so.
It's a safe bet that Mr. Cobblepot could have
a gang war on the horizon.
Speaking to Hero Nation, Reeves revealed that
the upcoming show would take inspiration from
the likes of machine-gun-toting gangster gem
"Scarface" and British crime classic "The
Long Good Friday."
Both films saw their lead character at the
top of their organizations, forced to go head-on
with competition, with unpleasant results
for both.
"Say hello to my little friend!"
The series is likely to see the Penguin make
new enemies — the kind that don't have pointy
bat ears.
Perhaps, a form of competition could arise
in the form of another drug.
Namely, could the drug Venom be making its
way to the world of "The Batman," and with
it, it's most famous user, Bane?
Many fans theorized that the green liquid
Batman pumped himself with to save Selina
was Venom, the go-to drug used by Bane in
the comics to increase his strength.
While it hasn't been confirmed whether this
was the mysterious green goo or it was simply
a shot of adrenaline, seeing Venom enter the
world of "The Batman" could lead to some exciting
conflict.
Perhaps this version of Bane would be a little
closer to the comics than the Tom Hardy incarnation
in "The Dark Knight Rises."
Could the Penguin's HBO Max spin-off see Cobblepot's
operation get muscled over by Bane?
In the process, could we find out the origins
of Drops and their manufacturer?
After all, we never did find out what the
character who is now confirmed to be The Joker
was in Arkham for.
The arrival of Venom, some other new drug,
or competing crime bosses could definitely
spell trouble for Cobblepot's now-flooded
empire.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.